hello everyone and thank you for joining
us for today's live webinar path forward
of mass spectrometry in clinical
laboratories I'm Christie Doyle of
labyrinths and I'll be our moderator for
today's event today's educational web
seminar is presented by lab routes the
leading scientific social networking
website and provider of virtual events
and webinars advancing scientific
collaboration and learning now let's get
started I would like to remind everyone
that today's event is interactive and we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at anytime you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation click on the
support tab found at the top right of
your presentation window or use that ask
a question box to let us know you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers free
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
your presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credit I would
now like to introduce today's speaker
dr. Amy Chang associate director of
point of care Department of Pathology
anatomy and cell biology at the Thomas
Jefferson University Hospital for a
complete biography on our speaker please
visit the biography tab at the top of
your screen dr. chan you may now begin
your presentation
Thank You Christy for the introduction
and thank you very much for joining us
today the topic I will be sharing with
you today is the path forward with mass
spectrometry and clinical laboratories
I just want to mention that I do not
have any disclosure
so to begin I will briefly describe the
evolution of mass spectrometry
application in clinical laboratories the
success of mass spectrometry in clinical
application can actually be traced back
to the 1980s when it was primarily used
to confirm drug testing and during that
time it was discovered that there was a
large number of false positive
immunoassay results therefore any
positive antibody drug screen was
considered presumptive positive until
confirmed by gas chromatography mass
spectrometry now moving forward to the
early 1990s the development of the
tandem mass spec for newborn screening
was introduced now this technology
became very important in detecting
congenital disorders in newborns which
later became a mandated screen in the
u.s. although the specific tests
performed vary among states now as the
new technology emerged in the mid-1990s
the development of MALDI combine with
tough which is time-of-flight and we
will discuss that a little bit more in
the next couple of slides allow for the
rapid identification of microbes which
this later became fda-approved and what
we implemented in the microbiology lab
this allows for decreased turnaround
time compared to the conventional
culture or biochemical tests
now fast-forward within the last two
decades liquid chromatography mass
spectrometry became popularly
implemented within the clinical
chemistry laboratories measuring
primarily small molecules such as drugs
vitamin D and steroid hormones now in
the yeast recent years around the 2010
mass spec application has extended to
protein and peptide analysis with the
development of more advanced technology
mass spec is now able to perform
high-resolution analysis now mass spec
is not only became the gold standard for
many clinical laboratory assays around
2013 several journals such as American
Society of endocrinology implemented
requirement for mass spec analysis to
publish steroid results so this
revolution of mass spec that we've just
discussed is driven by continuous
improvements in analytical platforms due
to clinical needs which are all anchored
by the analytical specificity of mass
spec now what is mass spectrometry so to
place very simply mass spectrometry is
an analytical technique that measures
mass-to-charge ratio of an ion mass
spectrometer produces large particles or
ions from the chemical substances that
are being analyzed the mass spectrometer
then uses electric and magnetic fields
to measure the mass or weight of the
charged particles
now I just wanted to very briefly go
through the you know the basic principle
of mass back there are main they're
forming components of mass packing in
the instrument such as at the sample
Inlet which is not describing this
figure which is place prior to the
ionizer the ion source the mass analyzer
and the detector first the analyte of
interest must be converted into ions
then ions are separated by the electro
magnetic field within the mass analyzer
then the detect then it is detected by a
quantitative method and process into
mass spectra according to the
mass-to-charge ratio which you can see
on the right Seeger the results are
typically presented as a mass spectrum
which is a plot of intensity as a
function of the mass to charge ratio now
there are very many different types of
analyzers what the first one that I
would like to introduce is the time of
flight tof half the speed of which the
ion travels for the toff is actually
dependent on the mass-to-charge ratio
and therefore the lower the master
charge ratio the faster you will travel
through the flight 2 than ions of larger
mass to charge ratio so it's a very
simple principle now I just wanted to go
over some of the applications of tough
one of them is used in the detection of
inborn error of metabolism so on this
figure that I'm showing is a profile of
a newborn infant of normal metabolism
profile so what I would like to show you
next
is the profile of a child born with MSU
D which is maple syrup urine disease
which is an autosomal recessive
metabolic disorder affecting
branched-chain amino acids
now the newborn carries a genetic
mutation in the gene complex that is
essential for breaking down the amino
acids such as loosing isoleucine and
valine in this particular patient there
is an accumulation of using isoleucine
which is very evident compared to the
normal profile that I just showed you
earlier
now the second application of tuff I
would like to show you is in the use of
drugs of abuse testing use a urine
specimen in this case this example I'm
showing here is a multiplex system where
you can detect multiple analytes in one
run within one sample they all have
distinct mass-to-charge signature
signature profile and therefore we are
able to separate each of them based on
that so you can see that there are
several different drugs within this one
specimens and you can pretty much
separate them individually and analyze
them the other common application of TAF
is in the rapid identification of
microorganism at the species level by
analysis of the integrable soma protein
of the bacteria the introduction of TAF
in microbiology laboratory has
significantly changed their workflow
maldi-tof mass spec is an innovative
tool that is easy to use rapid accurate
and cost-effective and it has
revolutionized bacterial identification
in clinical microbiology laboratories
the sample is Co crystallized with the
matrix on the target and beedis or and
ionized by multi ion source so in this
figure here you can see that once the
source hits the target it will be able
to ionize the protein O matrix in this
case which are the micro ribosomal
protein on the bacteria a niche spectrum
would be much too will be read based on
the structure of the ribosome and will
be matched to our database profile to
identify which micro organism it belongs
to
the other analyzer type is triple
quadrupole this technology has been
around since the late 1970s voltages
applied to the pairs of electrodes set
up an electric field that can cause ions
to oscillate down the central axis as
they travel through the device the
applied voltages determine which ions
are able to make it all the way through
to the detector effectively filtering
them so essentially one example I will
give you is say a compound a has a mass
to charge ratio of 271 so when it goes
through a triple quadrupole which is
consist of Q 1 Q 2 and Q 3 chamber one
can set filters detecting the specific
mass to charge ratio that you would like
to select for in Q 1 so in this case is
compound a which has a mass to charge
ratio 271 once it passes through Q 1 it
will get fragmented further in Q 2 and
therefore produce multiple daughter ions
or product ions and you can further
select for specific daughter or product
ions in Q 3 in this case we're selecting
for 145 charge mass to charge ratio and
therefore you're able to increase the
sensitivity in selectivity of what
you're looking for as I mentioned
earlier there is an increased number of
assays being measured using MS over
immunoassays due to its specificity
sensitivity and its ability to build
multiplex panel meaning that one can
measure multiple analyzed in one run per
sample some of the growing use of LCM is
in clinical chemistry include
therapeutic drug monitoring such as
immunosuppressant drugs and
antipsychotic drugs others include
biomarkers such as vitamin d steroids
and homocysteine the use of clinical
lc-ms has also extended to targeted
protein quantification such as thyroid
globulin igf-1 renin-angiotensin
the initial research work done on TDM
therapeutic drug monitoring were lithium
and venatori in the 1960s at the time
researchers showed that there was a
relationship between plasma
concentration of phenytoin in pet in
patients being treated for epilepsy and
the degree of seizure control attained
however it wasn't until the 1970s that
it became a routine practice in clinical
laboratories but with limited number of
drugs being tested however between late
1970s and 1990s there was a widespread
use of commercially available homogenous
immunoassay which resulted in the
explosive growth and therapeutic drug
monitoring because they were fast cheap
and easy to develop however they're not
without limitations in its application
clinical application which we will
discuss further in the next few slides
since the early 2000 the PDM trends
began to move back to lc/ms to overcome
some of the technical barriers such as
specificity and sensitivity
one of the issues regarding immunoassays
on TDM is its specificity as well as
sensitivity our sacrifice in certain sa
an example of this that I would like to
use is methotrexate which is a drug that
is used to treat several types of cancer
as well as psoriasis and rheumatoid
arthritis it is a drug with a very very
tight therapeutic range and some of the
toxic effects of this drug includes it
kills rapidly dividing cells such as
bone marrow and it is highly nephrotoxic
and it is it can cause cirrhosis and
chronic under chronic low dosing and
therefore often times it is used in
conjunction with rescue drugs such as
blue covarine and GU comedies one
problem with using bukhara days is that
it could cause some interference so what
is good carpet is it is actually a
bacterial enzyme that Cleaves met
attracts ate and renders it inactive
however during the cleavage it could
generate two non cytotoxic metabolites
which are dampe da mpa and glutamic acid
so in the figure in the middle shows the
concentration of methotrexate measured
by immunoassay versus lcms as you can
see immunoassay overestimate the
concentration of metal traction in the
beginning the treatment now the reason
is because as you can see on the figure
on the right GU carpet ace up the
structure of dampe
is very similar to meta tracks 8 and
because of that there is a high cross
reactivity using the amino acid antibody
and therefore you see a false elevation
of methotrexate concentration and it
loses its specificity and therefore lcms
is a better choice in terms of
monitoring the concentration of
methotrexate when patients are using GU
carpi days as the rescue
another note to mention is that um the
accuracy there's a huge effort in the
standardization and accuracy project for
immunosuppressant drugs that is commonly
used in transplant patients
the evolution of medication for
different targeted disease calls for a
need to be able to measure its
concentration in blood so some of these
are listed in this table as you can see
that a majority of this drug there are
so-called new generation anticonvulsant
drugs a lot of them do not have
immunoassay available in terms of
measurement and you can see that a lot
of them uses HPLC or a mass spectrometry
method to measure the concentration in
blood these days you can measure a panel
of drugs in one run per sample this
figure elegantly shows the separation of
a tiny drug panel in seven minutes
now each spectrum here represents each
drug or within one sample
TDM has also extended to measure
antifungal drugs such as triazoles such
ability to measure multiple analytes
brings value to those patients with
neutropenia either caused by
malignancies or chemotherapy bone marrow
transplant recipients end or other solid
organ transplant recipients because they
are commonly taking multi multiple
antifungal drugs at the same time so
this is just a figure showing that a
patient who is taking multiple drugs at
the same time so you can measure that
their different concentration with very
nice operation using mass back
other therapeutic drug monitoring that
uses mass spec also includes other neon
antineoplastic drugs such as do sulfon
therapy and therapy metabolites
here I wanted to discuss the hormones
measurements by lc-ms which is becoming
a demand among the endocrinologist the
measurement of hormones especially
steroid hormones requires high
sensitivity and specificity measurement
this is particularly important for low n
sex hormone measurements in the context
of a particular hormone in patients
suspected of sex hormone disorders which
are listed in the in the table
1:25 dihydroxy vitamin D is also
commonly used to be measured by lcms
this is due to its Pico molar
concentrations and its lipophilic nature
and therefore it's there are some
immunoassay depending on the vendor that
you use and there is not very
standardized and you get varying results
I'm using immunoassay method
another common hormone analyzed by mass
spectrometry is free t4 because thyroid
got'em thyroid hormones are usually
highly bound protein bound the gold
standard for free t4 is actually clearly
Broome dialysis
now one limitation of equilibrium
dialysis is that it is very laborious it
takes a long time to perform this test
by using lc-ms you could get a faster
turnaround time
I just wanted to point out the
importance of hormone measurement by
lc-ms by using estradiol as an example
in this case as you can see on the last
panel of the table the limit of
connotation of a direct immunoassay is
around twenty to thirty picograms per
mil now if you extrapolate this to the
figure on the right one can only capture
a specific population of condition such
as women receiving another drop in
therapy or pre menopausal women however
as you can see there's a sub population
of patients which are below the
detection limit of a direct immunoassay
and one could miss diagnosis so with
mass spectrometry one could measure as
low as one to ten picogram per mil of
estradiol in this case you can see that
how it is important to be able to
identify this a population of patients
that could be missed
if using immunoassay based on method
so there was a position statement that
was put out by the Journal of Clinical
Endocrinology and metabolism back in
2007
essentially they were evaluating the
current state of clinical assays for
total and free testosterone what they
found out was that laboratory
proficiency proficiencies testing should
be based on the ability to measure
accurately and precisely samples
containing known concentration of
testosterone not only on agreement with
other using the same method so at that
time a lot there was a lot of variations
in the measurement of testosterone using
different platform and they feel
strongly that in order to be able to
diagnose the patient's properly there
should be a consensus and to be able to
measure them accurately and this is
followed by another position statement
that was put out in 2013 which is very
similar but in this is in regards to
estradiol and therefore a consensus and
there was a consensus that came about
where if you were to publish any steroid
hormones specifically sex hormones and
the Journal of Clinical Endocrinology
one is to use a mass spec based method
to be able to that that is essentially
one of the requirements to publish a
paper so I just wanted to as I mentioned
earlier one of the application of mass
spectrometry in clinical labs is protein
analysis which is becoming more and more
important in common in clinical
laboratories some of the examples
include thyroid thyroid globulin igf-1
amyloid protein plasma renin activity
aldosterone and insulin
so I just wanted to point out that
there's a reason why it is becoming more
and more important to measure that are
globulin by lc/ms but before I talk
about the difference let me discuss a
little bit about why thyroglobulin what
are its utility in clinical setting para
globulin is the primary biochemical
tumor marker used to detect recurrence
in patients with differentiated thyroid
cancers the problem is that the result
can vary depending on which immunoassay
platforms that you use so there is no
standardization in terms of this assay
and it is found that twenty to
twenty-five percent of the patients with
differentiated thyroid cancer have
antiviral globulin antibody so when you
we deal with immunoassay one caveat is
that when a patient produces and keep an
teeth thyroglobulin antibody it could
interfere with the measurement of their
globulin because it could bind to the
reagent of the assay and therefore you
will not get a very accurate measurement
so this is a study that elegantly show
the effect of antiparallel good antibody
with the thyroid globulin we know si so
on the figure panel a what we're looking
at is patients with differentiated
thyroid thyroid cancer with
thyroglobulin antibodies negative so in
this patients one should assume that
they do not have any interference in
their immune assay because they do not
generate their own globin antibody and
as you can see in the black solid line a
majority of the patients when compared
to using immunoassay which is the first
bar column versus lcms second bar column
versus our gold center which is Radio
amino acid third column there is no
significant difference in terms of their
thyroid globulin measurement however as
you can see that there are some red dots
on this those are just
subpopulation of patience there were
only a handful of patients that do not
correlate at all for some unknown
reasons and if you look at the right
panel panel B these are differentiated
by direct cancer patients with thier
globin antibody positive and you can see
that when comparing using immunoassay
versus LCMS versus radio immuno sa a
majority of these patients their thyroid
globulin level is measured lower
compared to the conventional and gold
standard method which are LCM as an RIAA
so this strongly suggests that the
presence of thyroid globulin antibody
interfere with the measurement of Thera
globulin so therefore could present as a
false negative in terms of cancer
recurrence
so it became problematic
now I wanted to switch gear to discuss a
little bit about the utility of lc/ms in
monoclonal antibody therapeutics if you
recall the beginning of our presentation
lcms has the capability to analyze
peptides and proteins
now with the boom of immunotherapy for
cancer treatment monoclonal antibody
therapeutics are now widely used they
are currently more than 20 and
monoclonal antibodies that have been
approved by the FDA however there are no
assays available what they were known as
they's available to measure the efficacy
of this drug in patients until the
development of the method using lc/ms so
essentially this graph here shows that
the association between the stream
concentration of in fixie map which is a
monoclonal antibody and its efficacy
efficacy in patients with ulcerative
colitis so as you can see here on
patient who respond well to the
treatment they have a higher circulating
concentration of in 6mm in their blood
compared to patients with no response so
this allow for physicians to be able to
see whether or not the drug is effective
on the patient or whether or not they
need to adjust those of this therapy
you
now without going into absolute detail
on how one can use lc/ms to detect
monoclonal antibody but essentially if
you look at the graph on the left at the
bottom you can see that we could
differentiate infliximab with a Tolima
map in human serum and on the right hand
side you can see that this peak we
notice what this peak belongs to due to
its signature peptides so essentially we
can generate a signature peptides from
the protein of interest to perform
targeted protein analysis and thereby
being able to quantitate its absolute
concentrations what does the road ahead
of us look like in terms of adoption and
expansion of mass spectrometry so some
of the challenges that we face in the
lab in terms of adopting mass spec based
assays include access to the equipment
the capital cost for the equipment is
not cheap it is around 200 to 500
thousand per piece also it involves
training of skilled personnel this test
mass spec is considered a high
complexity testing in addition to that
mass spec is also considered a
laboratory developed tests because they
are not FDA approved that means that one
will require additional validation
before an essay can go live so what are
the drivers for continuous expansion for
mass spec based assay one of the most
important one is certainly the clinical
needs in order to that I presented I've
talked about earlier some of the
importance of accurate hormone
measurements steroid measurements and
vitamin D as well and also
high-throughput instruments so currently
which I'll discuss a little bit later
mass spec assays are not as high
throughput compared to automate
immunoassay however they'll works to
make them high throughput by multiple
vendors so that it can perform and more
volumes to decrease the cost the other
part
is also information technology and
vendor support currently they are not as
well supported to the conventional
automated platforms however it's been
involved there's been a lot of
discussion between vendors and
laboratories to improve those those
processes so I just wanted to quickly go
through the workflow and challenges of
mass spec tree how it can be manual of
borås and involves multiple workstation
so just quickly once when set when we
receive the sample one has to process
the sample by adding internal standards
which is sort of an internal control and
then somehow there would be involving a
protein purification step either it be
SPE or protein precipitation and then
the technologist would have to load
those samples onto the autosampler
which the probe would individually
sample H samples and that it would have
to go through the HPLC sample pump and
LC column which are the main separation
technology or the process that occur and
finally it would flow through into the
mass spec for analysis and each
individual process should be monitored
tightly and is still a very manual
process even though some parts can be
automated but there are multi cell that
can do analysis and once a spectrum is
generated so these are at the approved
where it incorporates chromatogram
analysis the integration and generation
of calibration curve
as I mentioned it is a multi-step
process and therefore one should
establish a sustainable workflow so
therefore we should include technologist
training on operation and result
analysis so I would suggest preparing a
checklist of things including
proficiency testing training daily run
information so tracking daily life
information should include sample
preparation such as kachu a lot
differences make sure that we log in the
individual catalog individual on buffer
lots open date and expiration date since
these are all manual made components and
also test run batch information mobile
phase column pressure mass spec
parameters all should be tracked daily
and data analysis is also an important
part on to monitor the internal standard
again something that I measure earlier
it's an internal control we wanted to
make sure the retention time of the same
analyte you're measuring always come out
at the same time you want to check the
peak shape and the analyte area making
sure that they are consistent and then
one thing is also to design a
troubleshooting workflow so as I
mentioned early in the previous slide it
involves so many components and any
component malfunction so it would be
helpful to design a troubleshooting
workflow for the technologist to go
about troubleshooting if they see an
increase pressure where should they look
at and whatnot and currently with the
tech support from the vendors are not
established as 24/7 so in order to have
them come and take a look at it might
take a day and therefore it's easier to
have the technology to perform initial
assessment of the issue it is also
important to note that one should have a
performance program monitoring program
and internal audit program
so essentially subscribe to cap PP
proficiency testing if no proficiency
testing is available one should do an
internal exchange with another lab that
perform the same test to ensure that
your you're getting consistent results
so how can we improve the workflow and I
mentioned that it's very manual some of
them are can be improved using sample
preparation the process can be improved
we could adopt a liquid handler platform
where the liquid handler is an automated
platform it could automatically pipette
a fixed amount of buffers a fixed amount
of washing buffers and reagents
so you would take out the manual part I
know that they are several vendors that
have currently developed an automated
analyzer that is very similar to the
chemistry automated analyzer I believe
it is currently being sold in Europe
however they're not currently FDA
approved to be used in the United States
they did however develop several kids I
believe the vitamin D kit is one of them
where you can buy a kit and you don't
have to develop the test it's already
that one it's an approved test what you
do is just put in little bottles it will
have all the parameters set you just
have to push one button and it would
analyze the sample just like in a
regular chemistry automated analyzer
that I've talked about the workflow I
just wanted to use the leftover time to
talk a little bit about the expansion
application of mass spec in terms of the
current state of it what are what is it
currently using research so clinically
mayo clinic has developed an assay that
allows for diagnosis of monoclonal
gammopathy so just briefly about
monoclonal gammopathy it's a disease of
the bone marrow where it generates
monoclonal malignant plasma cells a
monochrome immunoglobulins which are
then secreted into the bloodstream
the current conventional method is using
gel electrophoresis at the Mayo Clinic
they have developed an assay where they
can analyze the monoclonal antibodies
within the bloodstream and quantify them
as you can see on the right-hand side of
the figure
so as I mentioned before the gold
standard currently is using gel
electrophoresis however gel
electrophoresis has its own limitation
as well for example it is very
subjective to the reader because it's a
stained gel one might see a band and one
might not see a bane when it's faint
therefore there is a need for
improvement in terms of quantification
since this is some semi quantitative I'm
using the current method so what male
clinic have done is that they have
created a mass spectrometry called a
mass fix that is able to analyze a wide
variety of M proteins and they can
identify the proteins by the heavy and
light chain as shown on figure on the
right and they can even quantitate
the protein level in terms of
concentration
you
so the next exciting part about the use
of mass spec is in the measurement of
functional proteins on formalin-fixed
paraffin-embedded tissue FFPE and now
this is under research what you can use
do is that you take an FFPE tissue and
perform microdissection of the piece of
tissue and then process the tissue and
digest the tissue and subject it to
quantification detection within the mass
spectrometry the reason why we're
interested in using masks back to
perform protein quantification is
because the conventional method using
immunohistochemistry is again using
amine antibody so some of the antibody
based assay is not very specific or
sensitive and not all analytes or all
biomarkers have antibodies available for
performing IHC so in this case you can
get an absolute quantification whether
or not a patient expresses certain
biomarkers on the tissue cell surface
so I wanted to point out that one of the
clinically implemented case of mass
spectrometry assay is on ameloid osis
which is currently in clinical use it is
the edification of the type of amyloid
deposited is critical to the correct
diagnosis and treatment of patients with
this illness and therefore
characterization of systemic amyloid
deposits by mass spectrometry is already
in clinically implemented in several
hospitals and reference laboratories
some of the biomarkers are currently in
research include on the breast cancer
marker her2 and the immune checkpoint
PDL one which was actually presented at
one of the poster session which is a
collaboration between MD Anderson and
University of Chicago
so this is the end of my presentation
but I just wanted to quickly summarize
assemble two take-home messages from my
talk and I hope that the audience can
appreciate how far we have come in terms
of using this technology that's been
around for decades and how we are able
to advance medical diagnosis with its
implementation in clinical laboratories
now it is certainly not it does not come
without listen limitation there is this
upfront cost that we talked about how it
can be a big capital for some
institution and it also involves
personnel training and method
development and establishing a
sustainable workflow but I really
believe with increased demand and
practices calling for Standardization
there will be a push for an approval of
an automated system in the US now it
might take some time to be able to
formulate kit for each SI but I think
there is certainly a market for it so
with that I would like to thank the
audience for listening in and
participating in this webinar and I am
open for our live questions
dr. chan for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of our webinar now we
already have some great questions coming
in but as a reminder to our audience if
you do have a question you would like to
ask dr. chan just click on that ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and we will answer as many
of your questions as we have time for ok
let's get started
dr. chan let's go with this first
question what resources are needed to
establish a clinical mass spectometry
laboratory hi that's a really good
question so one would like would you
know start with the capital requirement
for purchasing an acquaintance equipment
so as I mentioned earlier it usually
caused about 200,000 to 500,000
depending on the resolution of the mass
spec that you're looking at and of
course the lab space one would make sure
that there is enough lab space to put
this equipment is a pretty big equipment
and the other one is clinical need
assessment is there a clinical need for
example I talked a little bit about some
of the immunosuppressants that can be
used to measure the using mass
spectrometry and with their need do you
guys have do we have a big transplant
program what is the volume to bring in
specific tests if we're sending out some
esoteric tests do we have an increased
volume that it could justify the cost to
bring it in-house so there are some of
things to consider and certainly not not
to forget training of qualified
personnel to perform high complexity
testing is important it does take some
time to train a personnel to be
competent at performing this very high
complexity testing in my personal
experience it sometimes takes four to
six months to train somebody without any
experience so certainly consider all
this points to establish a successful
mass spectrometry lab
thank you dr. sham our next question
since most MS assays are lab developed
tests how do you maintain an insurer
test quality
yeah so it is important to establish
performance monitoring program by
tracking daily data analysis such as you
know running to see monitoring the
internal standard looking at the
retention time making sure that what
you're measuring eludes out at the same
time all the time
so that we know that it's consistent is
the same and a lot you're looking at we
want to look at the peak shape making
sure you track the pressure and then the
most important thing is establish an
acceptable trash hole what is considered
as that acceptable now the you know the
lab director will have to establish this
because this is a lab develop test
there's no necessary guidance from any
regulatory body it is also important to
catalog and track Lots when you open a
new lot of certainly agents and make
sure that you put in our expiration date
and perform a lot to Lock comparison in
patients every time you change a lot you
make sure that you perform lots of uh
comparison making sure that the same
patient still measures the same despite
in changing the lot and it is also
important to perform internal audit
program or external audit programs such
as subscribing to cap peat proficiency
testing or alternate alternative
assessment program when one cannot
subscribe to PT because they don't have
it so you would want to exchange
specimens with other laboratory
performing the same test making sure
that you establish an acceptable number
or you know limit of error of what
you're looking at
thank you for MS analysis on proteins do
you pretreat samples to increase
sensitivity and specificity and if yes
how do you do that yeah this is a really
good question
so for protein analysis especially in
matrix such as the whole blood or serum
it is a good idea to pretreat the
proteins so for those who are not
familiar with this pre treating means
that if you have a blood or urine or you
know some specimen that is that consists
of many different kinds of proteins in
there how do you purify them to increase
sensitivity and specificity so it is
very common for one when they develop
this test to use a monoclonal antibody
to bind or sometimes people call it a
fish forward and which for a particular
protein of interest that you're looking
for so therefore once you have a
monoclonal antibody that binds to the
protein of interest it would precipitate
so therefore you can increase the
selectivity sensitivity of your si
another thing is to perform our albumin
depletion because most of most of the
specimens consist of high percentage of
albumin so if you can pre treat it with
albumin depletion treatment you can get
rid of abundant non targeted proteins
and therefore you can increase
sensitivity and specificity of your
assay
thank you now we have time for just a
few more questions but I want to remind
our audience that those questions we are
unable to answer today and those that
come in during the on demand period will
be answered by our speaker via the email
address you provided at the time of
registration dr. Tam
what are some of the limitations of the
multitask in the identification of
microorganism yeah so again the the top
limitation is of course the initial high
cost of the instrument but the
technology itself in terms of limitation
is the identification of new isolates as
possible only if the spectral database
contains peptide mask fingerprints of
the type strains of specific species or
subspecies so if the library or your
database doesn't have that you cannot
match it once it produces or generates a
perspective then you can't really
release the result because they don't
it's not in the database but however may
and I do know for sure that Mayo Clinic
has generated their own database where
they collect different strain and
species of microorganism and start
building their own database that they
commonly see therefore they have
actually a large library compared to the
standard ones that we get in the lab
from the vendor
now our last question you mentioned mass
spectometry replacing gel
electrophoresis how does one bill for
the test does it have a CPT code it's
actually a very excellent question so
that I am myself questioned that a whole
so so currently there is no CPT code to
order the mass fix SI which is the mass
spectrometry method of analyzing the
monoclonal antibodies for monoclonal
gammopathy I do know that Mayo Clinic
currently offered that to the patients
who are currently seen at the Mayo
Clinic in terms of how they get charged
I'm not so sure we will have to ask them
and I do know that if you were to order
it from a reference standpoint say you
know I don't have this test I want to
order it from Mayo how do we get bill
for that that I do not know I've never
send them send it to them before but I
do know is that they have submitted an
application to CMS to apply for a CPT
code so it would be interesting to see
by next year so if there would be a code
for them and you know and we would know
how to charge our patients because I
think that it will become more of a
standard practice to use that technology
in terms of measuring monoclonal
gammopathy instead of gel
electrophoresis
Thank You dr. chan do you have any final
comments for our audience
no is that I'm very excited to share
this discussion with all of you and and
I enjoy presenting this presentation
thank you for the opportunity lab roots
thank you and I'd also like to thank our
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions one last
reminder that those questions we were
not able to answer to today and those
submitted during the on demand period
will be addressed by dr. chan via the
email address you provided at the time
of registration I would like to once
again thank dr. Amy Chan for her time
today and her important research would
also like to thank lab works for
bringing you today's live webinar this
webcast can be viewed on-demand and
laboratory alert you via email when it's
available from recall we encourage you
to share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now and we thank you for
joining us have a great day